[Music]
hello and welcome to episode 37 of
GameSpot after dark GameSpot's official
video game podcast I'm your host Jake
Decker and this week joining me is Lucy
James Kelly plaguey hi and John Luke
psyche Cheers
this week we have quite a few things to
go through
we've got a couple games that we've been
playing that we want to talk about and
couldn't fallout 76 they just added
their wastelanders update there is more
cancellations it seems like Gamescom has
been cancelled in some sense and of
course we'll round out the show with
listener questions but before we get
into any of that how are you all doing
all right yeah you know how it goes you
know the vibes yeah this is now what
episode 5 or 6 in quarantine or in sulfa
self-isolation eyes have been that long
social distancing yeah I actually think
it's five episodes but if we count the
Final Fantasy spoiler spoiler episode
which I'm plugging right now if you
finished Final Fantasy you should
definitely check it out because it is up
there are six episodes that we've put up
while we've been in quarantine yeah I
mean I'm trying to force myself to go
outside of MO because I spent the last
couple weeks just staying in me and two
more started to do a thing where every
once in a while at the end of the
workday we'll go meet out in the little
courtyard as we live in the same like
building complex and that's actually
been really nice because it's like this
nice separation of like the day is done
I'm gonna go outside I'm gonna chat
face-to-face with tomorrow and then I
come back in yeah and it feels like a
like a nice clean break began work and
now not work I for the first couple
weeks I was walking the dogs to get a
break outside but the younger one that
can walk the longest broke his foot so
my my older dog the dog Lucy not the
human Lucy she can't walk super far
anymore cuz she has arthritis so I am
like what do I do
you know so I have not been going
outside but I ordered new Lululemon yoga
pants as an excuse to exercise official
lemons oh yeah like the real one like I
dropped a good amount of money on some
Lululemon [ __ ] cuz I I was like I need
well a I have two outfits that I did not
bring enough clothes with me so I was
like I don't have any shorts and it's
getting hotter so I needed to order
shorts so I was like okay I'm gonna
order like workout shorts and then I'll
have to work out so oh yeah I mean I
definitely have day sweatpants and
nights weapon to get to really get that
separation between I can't I can't
wheres my pants I can't either
I feel gross I was called wet jeans man
I am I can't read if I don't if I don't
have to be cut in half by my skinny
jeans then I absolutely will not be yeah
I think this is the difference between
women's jeans and men's jeans in terms
of comfort because my jeans are only
comfortable when I'm standing so yeah
dreams yeah I would agree I have a pair
of skinny jeans and I can't wear those
in the house absolutely not yeah I don't
own anything besides squishy
also this entire conversation I've had
the tik-tok for your cute jeans in my
head the Kardashians audio oh that's
what sir my G no I said your cute jeans
well anyway about them video games what
have you guys been playing jean-luc do
you wanna start yeah um I finished Final
Fantasy 7 remake since we last talked
I'll really have anything else new to
add that I didn't say last week without
like going into that ending which you
could check out a spoiler cast if you
want to hear that it's not really have
much else to say I'm more curious to
hear what you guys think about it I
think that's the big thing is like
having played it I'm just like so
curious to hear what other people think
about it I kind of want to know what
more like hardcore people think about it
especially like
deviations it makes as well as what like
new people like me think about it other
and then yeah otherwise I've just been
playing animal crossing a a lot of
animal crossing it's like it's fun it's
kind of nice it's like a daily routine
I like wake up every morning and I get
like a good amount like an hour of
animal crossing in every morning with my
girlfriend before before the day at work
and that's like nice but yeah it's kind
of it yeah not not too much else going
on in the world of John Luke in video
games we have them playing a game but I
guess we'll talk about that a little bit
later yeah I figured I would save that
for further and to kind of lead that
conversation all right
Callie what about you I'm still I've
still just been playing all the guys I
think I've been trying to do more like
Hangouts with friends via zoom and like
I've been spending a lot of time with my
family so I haven't started final
fantasy or doom yeah but those are the
two next ones I want to play my dad
especially really wants to play Doom
with me so I think we're gonna try to
get into that maybe after this show
because my mom is hanging out with her
friends online so I'll have an excuse to
play do but yeah I guess the the one
thing I wanted to talk about with Animal
Crossing was now that all the Big Spring
events for the beginning of April were
over we can kind of reflect on that
first event roll out for New Horizons I
would say like I actually I enjoyed
bunny day I think it overstayed its
welcome a little bit but I didn't hate
it the way other people did mostly
because I don't think it replaced
anything like it didn't like yes it
replaced some resources day to day like
you'd get eggs instead of stone or
whatever but like you could also totally
not shoot those balloons if you wanted
to after a little while I was tired
hearing the sound of the balloons but
whatever I do think it was not a good
idea to have a bunny day and the fishing
tourney overlap because fishing up eggs
when you're trying to do the fishing
tourney
not good that actually only happened to
me once but it is that it happened to
other people a lot more and I think that
was not the best timing that happened to
me enough that it was definitely very
frustrating I think the one I'm was more
bummed about was the the cherry blossom
then I didn't realize how short it was
yeah I didn't realize either I thought
cherry blossoms would be it like I
thought it would be all of April because
I don't time-travel so I had no idea and
the guide got delayed so I super have no
idea oh did it yeah so I've just been
going off of like people that I know who
time travel who tell me thanks because
I'm just like I I don't want to
reproduce I just don't want to it's like
fine if you want to but that's not how I
plan a little crossing so I will not go
that fork far for a guide I like writing
guide so not that much yeah so I thought
it would be longer I did I grinded out
balloons for seven straight hours to get
all of the cherry blossom recipes which
was insane and it really does feel like
cherry blossom season you're not meant
to get all of the recipes in one year
didn't stop you though it did not stuff
for me because I really like cherry
blossom stuff a whole lot it's I think
one of the cool things about the way
it's implemented at Animal Crossing is
at least in Japan cherry blossom season
it's like a really big deal you have
Hunnam you which is the cherry blossom
viewing which is like a big event when I
was in Japan I saw like the one I was
there at the in March so before cherry
blossom season but a couple trees have
bloomed and there were like tons of
people standing around the trees so you
do get that like it's it's so beautiful
because it's so brief but in terms of
collecting in Animal Crossing it's like
but I want to make the blossom Lantern
so it's like the beauty of nature versus
completion ISM but I
I don't think cherry blossom season and
bunny day overlapping it was too much of
it issued because they were separate but
the fishing tourney was just like one
too many things I feel like the fishing
tourney could have been this coming
weekend yeah so that's just like a
lesson you know Nintendo doesn't really
do a lot of live service games that's
something a little bit newer to like the
switch really you have DLC for breath
the wild for fire and bloom for Pokemon
and now for Animal Crossing to get like
real ongoing support it's kind of a new
frontier it's not an excuse for it to be
rocky because obviously on going live
service games are not a new phenomenon
but for Nintendo I'm like okay you'll
figure it out
and I think they also have a
disadvantage of also weird way to phrase
it but you know no one knew when they
designed these events that we'd all be
stuck at home so obviously it's going to
feel like oh my god these eggs but
generally I mean my experience with
Animal Crossing in the past is playing
for that hour in the morning and then
maybe an hour at night and not playing
for hours and hours straight as we have
been doing so those are my thoughts on
those events yeah I just add to that I
got three cherry blossom recipes and two
are the same I got a repeat that earlier
I think it was I forget what it was but
it was it no it was the picnic it was
the bonsai is the bonsai tree did you
get the one I said yeah I got the one
you sent me that when I had to rip yeah
so I kind of struck out but that's okay
oh I guess I'll get him next year I also
I do really want to say really quickly
but I watched portion of a lady on fire
last night that movie was absolutely
beautiful I want to I want to watch that
Greg in general watching it I think a
couple weeks ago but I was having a date
night over zoom so I didn't watch it but
it like that the beginning got me
interested
it might the elevator pitch is in a
French film about a female painter who
is hired to paint a portrait of a woman
there in like the I want to say the
1800s or something a portrait of a woman
to send to her suitor as like a do like
how she looks marry her then but but she
the the woman who has to get married
doesn't want to get married and then
old-timey gayness happens I was gonna
say I was getting that vibe yeah there's
subtitles then cuz I can't do subtitles
so I won't do sometimes that's such a
[Laughter]
sight yeah you so fair sight there uh
there are yeah but I didn't read any of
the subtitles ok I didn't have a clue
what was going on the whole time just
watching the shots were nice yes well
this house I watch everything with
subtitles my own I know me too
I felt I felt bad like so time and I do
the west-world breakdowns but we do them
on screeners so they don't have
subtitles and so it means that every
time you hear like a Westworld version
of a song it's just me and time trying
to figure out desperately what it is and
it's been so like it's been so sweet
because the people who watch every week
they go guys why don't you just watch
with the subtitles of like also Lucy I
have to confess that we when we watch
loved Island we buy group that oh you
have to put the subtitles we put the
subtitles on because there's too many
Geordie asked people for like why sorry
I sent this to you but there is a
Netflix it looks trashy as hell it's
coming out today yes today me Gregg and
Jenn or like we've we've cleared our
Friday we're just gonna watch it it's
basically a new Netflix show about a
bunch of hot people I guess they're on
holiday or in an island and the rule is
that they lose money if they have sex
with each other
it's just like the blue
concept and it's like the office of love
island but it's like a weird mix of
Australian and British people there's a
bunch of people from Essex in there and
an Australian guy from what I could see
on the trailer and I was like just I
can't wait to watch it this looks awful
if I don't hear muggy melt oh yeah
absolutely
Mel Mel I've never seen the trailer for
it there's like it's like a robot
telling them what to do yeah it's like
an AI because I remember one of the guys
is like no grobotz gonna tell me who I
can and can't have sex with but I'm like
maybe I need to watch this we don't
watch in the circle the circle didn't
really do it for me in terms of trash TV
cuz we also started to watch Rock of
Love oh you could not make can't make a
show like that anymore let's put it that
way yeah I do so it on the subject of
like romance TV um there's a season of
The Bachelor happening right now I
basically only watched a couple episodes
of The Bachelor in my life so I don't
know a lot about it but it's like music
themed and a guy I went to high school
with it's on the show
so now I'd watch yeah he's really really
nice and he's a really talented musician
so it should be cool are you guys
familiar with Nikki jakey on YouTube yes
he did a really good video I think the
history of like trashy dating shows and
like why he loves them it's really good
it's a really entertaining video highly
recommend his video essays on that kind
of stuff are always way more
entertaining in my opinion than his
video game ones like his video game ones
no I agree but like I always get more
excited when i sees got a new outlet
upload and it's just about some random
thing he talked about but fair you
should definitely watch the one about
dating shows yeah cuz he bathed his
conclusion is like basically just like
I'm depressed
and I love these and I'm like it's all
of us he's all of us he last one last
one on 90 day fiancé there's a man who's
been dating a Russian woman for seven
years
and he's gone to Russia to meet her for
the first time because never better she
told him to meet her somewhere she
didn't show up so he's gone to her
hometown and it's hoping to just bump
into her on the street he's definitely
getting catfished the end oh my god so
that's what I try queueing or check
their stressful ones I want to watch the
track of love right is that he ends
every sorry hold on whoa what is the
premise of raqqa flow like oh my god
so Rock of Love is from like 2006 its
Bret Michaels from the band Poison and
okay this is a winning formula already
yeah yeah it's all on Hulu and the
premise is basically it's something like
20 odd women and they really ham up the
the rocker chick the like they give them
so much booze they are clearly on drugs
too in that first episode and then oh
yeah Bret Michaels has a body got a
bodyguard called Big John and Big John
kind of like does the weird thing of
like vetting the girls for him and to
get to the next round like in The
Bachelor it's the rose but in this you
get a backstage pass but also the reason
I said earlier you couldn't make a show
like this these days is because first of
all Bret Michaels calls the ball oh yeah
look the babes inviting the girls to
like stay in the competition and one of
them's like oh and you know cut member
name just fantastic breasts you know
it's like I mean yeah and there's the
first time there's like 20 odd women and
they get rid of I think five or six of
them
and it's so awful because it's all the
older ones yeah it's like you just
couldn't couldn't get away with this
state the mid-2000s word what time step
yeah yeah also he says things like I was
having this conversation with her and it
was really turning me on but he says the
phrase really turns me on like episode
is it like take a shot every time he
says really turns me on
yeah pretty much pretty much that's all
right I've also been Final Fantasy
speaking of horny on main I was about to
say what do you thought so far in Final
Fantasy IV you Tifa girl well I'm a Tifa
girl but I admit I'm at the section now
where I'm like hanging out with Aerith
and I do love her but I think teef is
always gonna be my best girl I do love
Jesse - I love them all but I didn't
expect to fall so hard for remake
because I have no real connection to
5007 even like the first time air its
steam kicked in so I've been to a few of
the concerts and so I knew the song but
I was like oh I actually genuinely had
like chills let me love the comment
system that's probably my favorite
combat system I mean kind of it's on par
with persona 5 Royals with the nice
changes they've made to that like so I'm
playing these two games at the same time
so I'm really getting my fill of hot
Japanese teams being like I'm seeing
saving the world I I feel like what
you're saying about like how you feel
nostalgic for it even though you don't
really have any experience with it is
like something that I'm feeling too and
I think a lot of people are feeling as
well who haven't played it just because
like that game is so iconic even if you
haven't played it you recognize the
characters you recognize the music you
recognize the setting like everyone
knows midgard knows there's the reactors
around the center and stuff like that
but even like you know as someone who
like I remember people were talking
about I was like yeah I don't really
care too much about it I'm gonna play it
cuz I'm curious then it got a 10 and I
was like alright I gotta play it
but like that opening scene even when it
is it's it's an exact remake of the
opening scene from the original - and I
had seen that and like when you hear the
music come in it is pretty stunning and
then I even went back to play the
opening of Final Fantasy 7 I think what
I'm gonna do is play the original Final
Fantasy 7 app pace with the remake so
I'm gonna play like the first couple
hours and then wait three years for Part
two whatever well I don't know maybe
I'll end up playing more but my
reasoning behind it right now is that
there's so many other games I want to
play and I already just spent 40 hours
on the Final Fantasy game I don't want
to but yeah just the like seeing that
seeing that in the original - after just
finishing it was like I don't know it's
it's so it's so cool it's so impressive
yeah it's been so interesting like my
conceptions of what these characters
were based on like pop culture yeah and
see what they actually were so I was
like oh cloud he's the quintessential
emo anime boy and that's kind of like
like just but then and he is that to a
degree but there's so much more to him
in this game that I it's like oh there's
like cloud ISM has way more depth than I
just thought he had or like Aerith who I
you know is like oh she's you know like
kind of like the the pure you know like
the goody two-shoes goody two-shoes but
it's like she's not that at all she's
actually like she's super cool and like
you know her whole character is - she
just kind of like picks cloud apart and
like cloud it's like I'm a tough badass
and she's like like or not yeah but I
like you anyway and I'm like oh man like
I the character dynamics are like so
well done and it's it's like it's really
interesting having a game that I guess
just like because I've I've heard about
it for so long I kind of had my it's
this feels shitty to say but like I I
sort of had my like preconceptions of oh
yeah yeah I know what Final Fantasy 7 is
about and then like playing this I'm
like oh I totally didn't know I had no
idea what it was really about and and
it's like really nice and it totally
makes me want to go back and play that
original to aspire
after I did that spoiler cast and
hearing them talk about just how much
they loved it
Nick in particular Nick Sherman huge
like I think he said it's his favorite
game of all time and like the passion he
talks about that original game makes me
want to go back and play it yeah I'm
like if I'm not to JRPG doubt after
finishing royal - I do want to go back
and play original just like I said
before move on my friend was I think I
was talking to my friend about it and he
was like mm I love you original this
one's been kind of namur it a little bit
and I was like yeah I see what you mean
you know personally being a Kingdom
Hearts fun I think he's definitely
reined it in but I mean I don't think
it's Kingdom Hearts level of no no I'm
sorry like there's certainly some there
were this like elements of Nomura that
having played like Kingdom Hearts you
can definitely identify he was like yeah
but I'm a completionist so I just bought
Kingdom Hearts 3 does it what do you do
way more for me
peak more but yeah I would also say item
or sub this on the spoiler cast but even
though like I would agree there is
certain amaura miss to it I I do think
that is a disservice to the rest of that
writing team like there's so much like
depth and care put into like the small
character moments that I think like I
think to to dismiss it as Jess like oh
it's been Nomura fide he's like very
very dismissive and there's so much to
that game yeah I mean I think I think
you see a lot of that early on just in
how you get introduced to these
characters and at first like I don't
know probably for the first 10 minutes
right they're like okay at least I was
thinking these are very JRPG ish
archetypes like you've got this
character in this character and within
minutes I feel like it does a very good
job of telling you like oh wait no hold
on there's a lot more to these
characters then just you know Barrett
yelling in an elevator like sure he
seems like this bombastic character but
he actually has you know he wears
hard on asleep which i think is
something tomorrow even said in his
review which yeah is something that I
found really impressive just because I
have played quite a few JRPG well
actually haven't played that many
considering all the ones out there but
okay yeah but I haven't played like any
Final Fantasy games other than this
I haven't played Chrono traders all
these JRPGs that people just a classic
so I haven't pledged I want to be
careful there depending on how old you
are there's gonna be tons of games you
haven't played that doesn't undermine
that's the truth I don't know I I still
don't think I've played a whole lot
because I feel like most of the JRPGs I
played when I was younger we're just
Pokemon games alright tales of Bruce
Area reviewer for GameSpot calm ok yeah
living that I'm only played like I've
only played like three of the [ __ ]
40k games so I'm just being careful
covering my bases here by saying aye
anyway basically what I was trying to
say was that I am very impressed with
how quickly they shake those archetypes
and how interesting these characters get
quickly and how they continue to develop
throughout the story I'm curious to see
how their arcs are gonna keep going
throughout the next three games but yeah
I'm really enjoying it so far anyway
yeah I mean I've mostly been playing
Final Fantasy 7 remake - I actually just
finished it a couple nights ago so I've
switched over to fallout 76 because
they've added the wasteland news update
on Luke and I have been playing a bit of
that and so it's interesting I mean I'm
sure I was more impressed with it at
first and I feel like I'm less impressed
with it the more I play it like I think
it's more that it's not as much of an
overhaul as I was hoping it was what do
you miss he's like do they add anything
meaningful so that that's the
interesting thing right like I've played
I think I've played more than John Luke
right now the wasteland is updating and
when you first get out of vault 76
you're pretty much introduced to like a
bar where you can complete quests for
this woman and they're very
like they feel like fallout quests and
that there's skill checks there there
are different ways you can tackle
missions there are like dialogue trees
and whatnot and all that well I thought
was pretty interesting and I enjoyed it
for the most part like you yeah
I don't know if I'd say it was up to par
with like yeah I don't know it's tough
to say on the quality of writing because
I haven't played enough of it I think
it's better than fallout 4 we were
talking about this the other day we're
playing what we've seen yeah like I've
laughed more at some of the situations
than I did in the entirety of Fallout or
there's just more there like fallout 4
it had like that very it was like that
magic there's four options and we were
kind of talking about how I it felt like
you there wasn't much of a character you
could create with those options this
feel because it's just text and your
character doesn't talk it feels like
they have a huge amount of variety and
how your character can respond so even
though it's probably not anywhere near
the levels like a new Vegas I feel like
it's a step in the right direction it
feels like they've they've learned their
lesson from fallout 4 at least and it
feels more substantial than that the
interesting thing about it though is
that right after you complete this quest
line for this woman which was kind of
interesting because like I said you
could tackle it different ways like I
think you even had the option to join
the bandits if you wanted to it none of
us pick that but if you wanted to you
could join the bandits and just kind of
like screw over this tavern if you
wanted which was interesting and that's
you know classic fallout fare so I was
happy to see that but a couple issues
that we were in into is one of them was
that you know how like in Borderlands
for example if you're questing with a
friend you complete quest together so
like if if we want to be on a team we
can play through the entire story
together we can go and I'll to all the
dungeons together we can do that stuff
together with fallout 76 when you go
into interiors you can't complete quests
with your buddies now I I'm having
trouble explaining this because I it's
really strange but basically like so for
example there was a cave that we had to
go in and rescue some robot thing and
John Luke went in and we could either go
with jean-luc and accompany
accompany him on this quest which we
also had to complete but it wouldn't
complete for us because he probably has
made different choices than we have yeah
so you win why not instanced version of
that cave so they'd be entering my
instance yeah it's a better way to put
it yeah so like you Jake wouldn't get
the complete you'd have to do it again
in your own instance in order to get
exactly yeah so we didn't we were there
was me John Luke and Matt and we ended
up just like every time we got to one of
those areas where like we're just gonna
do this by ourselves because otherwise
we're gonna have to do it multiple times
just to complete it which is it's like
an interesting problem right because I
don't know how you can fix that easily
cuz you people want narrative decisions
they want choice they want the story to
change but obviously you can't do that
for everyone so you have to do something
like that but at the same time it's like
why then why am i playing with friends
if if like we we can't play with each
other during these crucial story moments
which almost kind of makes me wish it
was more like divinity original sin
where it was just common or divinity
original sin to or just kind of like you
have a character for this campaign that
you're going to play with your buddies
with and like that character is not
necessarily useful outside of that
campaign yeah or like I know if you ever
play the Old Republic
MMO that game had these areas I figure
out they're a call but they're basically
like these instances where you would do
like a mission with multiple people and
everyone would actually participate in
the dialogue and essentially when you
would get the option to pick a choice
everyone would pick the choice they
wanted to pick and then the game would
roll a die to determine who won and
actually got to say what they wanted to
say and that would determine where what
actually happened but you would like you
would technically still get like good
points for doing the good thing but then
like the person your party who's like
we're gonna kill them all with like when
the the dice roll so then you'd be like
I guess we're killing them all but it
wouldn't like affect your alignment
that's good that system had problems but
seems better than this it allowed you as
a party to still like participate and in
the story with each other and I like I
have rather it done that
it just feels like we're it doesn't feel
like we're playing the game with each
other it feels like we're just on
discord with each other talking while
we're playing these story moments
separately yeah and I will say like some
of the story moments I've had I thought
were pretty good like I thought they
were engaging or funny or entertaining
or or like some of it I thought was
pretty well written but once again like
when we're playing as a group a lot of
that stuff is lost on me and I mean I'm
sure other people like will experience
this as well so I've actually been
enjoying surprise surprise I've been
enjoying fallout 76 more on my own than
with friends and I I think like I if
you're gonna play it I'd recommend just
doing it by yourself at least getting
through that story by yourself and then
maybe grouping up with friends but there
is still one very weird thing where you
can start this sort of NPC questline
story right when you get out of vault 76
but after you I don't know do like four
or five quests you get gated you have to
hit level 20 before you can continue you
find a character and she's like you're
not tough enough for what I have to do
for you and it's like reach level 20 and
I'm just like come on like which
basically means doing the original
game's main story exactly been changed
at all it's the exactly because in
theory the outcome of the of the
original story would be wrapped up when
you meet this character so it's just it
feels designed for people who played it
and then we're coming back rather yeah
totally it feels like it doesn't work at
all as a brand new player and it's like
an overhaul it feels more like I was
meant to have already finished this and
now I'm coming back because the idea was
like oh the NPC's are returning to the
the Appalachia after a year of no one
being there but then you play that
original story that's still there and it
still has that like melancholy
everyone's dead vibe but now these
random NPCs scattered around your mark I
feels like they'll add they'll add NPCs
to these missions that originally didn't
have them so they don't do anything
they're just there for you to talk to
which to be fair like can be
entertaining like so far I've met some
cool characters but it's just like the
only reason you're here is so you can
say there's an NPC here now but this NPC
literally has nothing to do with what I
am doing it's also still buggy as hell
yes multiple crashes a combination of
genres that just hasn't quite been
figured out like there's a similar thing
in in destiny too and they try to like
make a big narrative change but like so
like cayde-6 dying was like oh no he's
everybody's favorite character so AI
don't know why you'd do that but be he
was his voice was still in old like
strikes strikes and stuff so it wasn't
like he had died at all you're just like
I was playing this I'm doing a strike
playlist anyway so I was here like the
story the actual story much like level
mission that's about him was so good but
outside of that it doesn't there's just
it's a really hard balance to just
strike like I don't know how like Final
Fantasy 14 does it for example but I
know the story is really lauded in that
game maybe this is a question for
Michael later but I I just I don't know
how you make something tailored to an
individual narrative wise while also
being multiplayer in the way that
fallout 76 aims to be yeah like any game
I've played has ever really truly
figured it out like we another example
the Bethesda one is like Elder Scrolls
online like me Matt and Jake try to play
that with each other and that game is
like it's got a lot of a story and
dialogue and like written dialogue but
it you can't do any of that in a group
like it would be like hey guys I need to
go listen to this character talk for 10
minutes while you guys just stand there
yeah exactly and you're sitting there
being like isn't this supposed to be
like a co-op game I put my friends but
like I keep having to stop and telling
everyone to shut up so it can be hear
this dial
I I will say though like just to bring
it back to fall at 76 I am enjoying it I
don't know if I want to say
significantly more than when I first
played it but I am enjoying it
considerably more than when it first
came out there like it's still buggy but
there are less bugs it seems like
they've made a lot of refinements a lot
of quality of life changes like when I'm
not doing the story when I'm just
exploring with friends like that world
is still very good it's very fun to
explore which is something I think John
Luke you have talked about a lot when
the game came out which it wasn't really
getting credit for and I like I'm
excited to play more I just yeah I the
the story is really strange I'm gonna
keep chugging away on the story cuz I I
want a game like that and I'm hoping
maybe there'll be something to it but as
of right now like apart from some of the
conversations I've had with characters
it it just seems like it doesn't seem
like a big overhaul that people are
expecting it seems more just like well
here's here's these NPCs that are here
now yeah well we are gonna have a review
on GameSpot so keep an eye out for that
hmm and I'm making a video about it as
well so you can check that out later did
we did everyone talk about what we've
been playing what we've been doing yeah
only talk about the new strokes album
which I haven't had it yet it's so good
it's not good and and you know it's good
because Anthony Fantana gave it like a
pretty good score which you know a lot
of times I'll listen to an album and
I'll think it's good and I'll watch his
review and I'll be like okay maybe this
albums bad but no he and I was like a
sigh of relief because I've been
listening to it all week yes thank god
that's very good
I recommend it anyway new XCOM game
announced we're on to news was announced
XCOM camara squad what is I actually
know nothing about this picture for me
it is a spinoff XCOM game so it's not a
sequel to X come to
um but it's still like XCOM it's not
like X can't pick her ass or something
which I would love that sounds like cool
yeah like original idea do not steal and
that is the extent that I do about it
however we will have a review with this
game as well review we review big games
and it is coming out very soon I think
the 24th oh wow
one of the cool things about those that
is $10 for I think the rest of the month
like when it comes out to their ass
month in there to go up to 20 so it's
pretty cheap like it sounds like if you
enjoy XCOM that's kind of a you might as
well go for it personally I haven't
played much XCOM our XCOM guy doesn't
work here anymore but like I am pretty
terrible at it
I could never play it on Iron Man but I
like it a lot and they it just came on
switch right I think it's going Turner
or excellent pick that up and sort of
work my way back up the phone pick it's
kind of weird that this is coming out
like around the same time as Gears
tactics which is also an ex-con also
coming out see yeah I don't know if
that's just a coincidence or not but I
don't know why it's weird that like the
only other game that's like XCOM heavily
ex-con inspired is I coming out the same
week and then they drop like a brand new
thing XCOM busses I'm just gonna get
overwhelmed and just play firearm law
but um so that's yeah
XCOM camara squad every time I see the
word chimera I think about Full Metal
Alchemist
oh yeah oh I thought you're gonna do it
John Luke D hit oh sorry
oh no duty on do it again I think about
Full Metal Alchemist
Full Metal Alchemist thank you did you
see right along here did you see someone
with no anime
in an animal crossing design it's very
good mmm
that should be your town flag yeah I
should make that my temp I do that
anyway in other news game spa Gamescom
oh my god
games come has been kind of cancelled so
they said on Twitter that they still
want to do a digital event however the
like all all events have been shut down
for the foreseeable future and
apparently yeah no they tweeted a weird
thing about things that old Christopher
Reeves quote about you know standing up
and always being there or something it
was like a very bizarre quote that
basically sort of insinuated that they
didn't want to shut down but well six
men it's what July July yeah yeah but
games comes August right genetic if
they're already canceling and probably
should too although it seemed like games
come I don't know based on the tweet it
seems like they didn't really have a
choice oh that's a mandate put in place
by the gym yeah so so I I wonder we
probably don't have them I don't know if
we have a mandate here that's saying
that like you can't wait Simon come san
diego's that'd be nice oh my god gavin
newsom yes so he they haven't got a date
on any of that stuff yet so there isn't
an official like end date they sort of
talked about the rollout of the
reintegrating people back into society
sort of thing yeah i know in in LA
county the shelter in place was extended
to May 15 last time I checked but they
San Diego is an LA County but it's
probably similar yeah but anyway I can't
come is gonna be interesting to be an
online one cuz over the years they've
kind of moved away from being the big
place where everything gets announced to
just being the hands-on place and so if
you don't have your 400,000 people in
the cone Messer
queuing up to get hands-on with demos I
don't know how it's gonna work is an
online event unless it's like a mini e3
but then if they if they go back to
their old ways of like having press
conferences and whatever but yeah I
don't know
put demos on Google stadia yeah that
people try them at home ma I can't think
of who like the even the phrase hands-on
I'm just like no I don't want hands-on
anything I do not want to pick up the
control that other people have been
using I'm so crowded like I was thinking
about yeah like Anna's wedding a lot of
the anime Khan's we're kind of slow to
get cancelled like fanime just got
officially cancelled but like Anime Expo
is in the same convention centers III
but it is so many more people like
wall-to-wall packed people pass out from
heat exhaustion
lengua god no Gamescom is also so packed
I don't want anything to do with that
kind of thing right now I can I went to
PAX East right before it was like right
before everything that was scared off
yeah and it was like you know it was
like before anything really kicked off
but like I just remember feeling a lot
of anxiety being there and that was like
before things happen
okay can I even even if technically
everything's fine by the time like
Gamescom err Comic Con happens like I
still don't want to go anywhere near
anything like that for a while yeah
until like I know it's like truly 100%
like good absolutely not yeah yeah
before them is a great show and it's
like one of my favorites
but then at the same time like I I stay
in the business area I don't go in the
halls because like it's impossible to
get anywhere and like the holes are big
enough that even though it's packed you
don't feel like you're being like sort
of crammed in with people but they're so
big and there's so many people that it's
easy to feel lost in there and it takes
like ages to get from one to another
there's so many right also they don't
have air conditioning in the main or if
they do it's not good mm-hmm but no I
yeah I'm intrigued to see how that's
gonna work yeah I was just gonna say
before this I the only time I felt
nervous about like germs during demos
was VR stuff and now I'm like oh next
time there's an e3 I'm gonna use hand
sanitizer after every hands-on like
little things like that I'm thinking
about how my approach is gonna change
and so this is my favorite piece that
PAX East was uh it's the 2020 xx booth
and that guy just had multiple giant
Costco size bottles of hand sanitizer
he's like I'm ready I'm ready for it can
you hand sanitizer we have some before
have some after like you're my favorite
guy my favorite guy here you know what's
up well moving on then to a new crisis
game in the works possibly so the
background behind this is that the
crisis account tweeted hey Nomad you
still with us and receiving data on
April 14th and 13th that's the first
time first time they've tweeted in four
years it looks like someone found the
account this is interesting
oh boy I mean Crytek is still around
right they could still do it there's
just showed it but that game is I mean I
think they're just updating it yeah over
time but I think it's mostly done I love
the original Crysis it's like one of my
weird no cult classic is the right word
but it's sort of like it's this it's a
game that I I like legitimately loved
the first game and I think it's so good
and part of it is because it was
basically a sequel to the original Far
Cry in terms of like the design and and
sort of like okay each area is a sandbox
and and the the way you could interact
with enemies and the AI and the
different like suit powers like I would
just play levels over and over again and
do them in different ways
do them on different difficulties and I
loved it and I absolutely hated Crysis 2
because they got rid of it all of that
and they just made it this like linear
like shooter that just felt like it was
trying to be every other shooter it like
all the personality got sucked out of it
I didn't even bother playing the third
one which I heard was like better than
the second but it still wasn't that
open-ended thing that the third one was
so like I definitely won another game
like Crysis 1 like playing like Crysis 1
but in terms of like Crysis is a
franchise I don't really care that games
story is like batshit insane I like
looked up like the plot synopsis for
Crysis 3 and it is like literally the
most insane like plot I've ever read
like it is absolutely insane you should
look it up sometime it's wild
also they that tweet said Nomad which is
the character from Crysis 1 he dies in
like a comic book in between Crysis 1
and 2 apparently so I'm like what does
that even mean are you bringing back in
the head
are you remaking Crysis 1 are you
retconning it I don't even know like
it's just I like I said I love Crysis 1
but I look at this and I'm like I don't
even I don't even know like I don't what
is this I trust you to still make a good
crisis one because you you had a chance
to make a sequel that game and you
messed it up twice also like Ubisoft is
like kind of use nomads for like half
their protagonists recently like the
Ghost Recon games out really mad and
siege they added a nomad get an operator
named Nomad so when I see it I'm like
huh as Crytek like using their engine
for a gostrey I don't know like I'm just
like I like it takes a while to get to
there nobody nobody's like oh yeah Nomad
the main character of Crysis 1 like :
things that no one cares I love that
game I don't care dude the only thing I
know the only thing I know about crisis
is just but can it run Crysis and the
suit going maximum armor maximum
strength like put that in there and I'm
good like like you need it if they
tweeted maximum strength I'd be like
let's go let's do it yeah I'm on board
yeah I mean I think at this point the
thing
be most interested in is just to see
what absurd boundary they plan on
pushing in terms of graphics cuz I feel
like that was the thing with the first
one even though I couldn't play because
I wasn't able to run it a lot of people
come play because I run it it was still
cool to see like here's everything they
managed to fit in a game cuz the game
still looks great and that came out what
almost a decade ago over a decade ago I
don't know a long time ago so it's
that's definitely what interests me the
most as of right now like just seeing
what they do with it but yeah like I'm
not like oh crisis I'm so excited we got
a new one
however oh do you want to say I was just
going to mention is somebody I forget
who in the in the GameSpot discord
shoutout to the GameSpot discordant put
a video that was like a modded version
of crisis one that uses like ray tracing
that can just don't look so good
like the water tech we like the ray
tracing models like damn we did actually
been done Joey did one yeah Joey potato
motive crisis too late too late
shoutout to potato Joey I will say
though I am excited for a resonable for
remake oh yes I know that's a bit
controversial yes I mean if they do what
they did with Ari - and not what they
did with re3 I'm so curious I keep going
back and forth on it because there's
that part of me that's like Resident
Evil 4 is perfect and you don't need to
change anything about it but at the same
time I'm like like I don't know maybe
there's all that like cave stuff after
the new mansion like the castle that I'm
like yeah maybe you could cut some of
that maybe you did clean it up a little
bit I hope in any ways acting though I
don't want them to change the voice
acting I hope they I hope they like that
and like even evenly on Leon's like I'm
a cool badass like ooh anime character
where does my lingo I want to I want to
see that with who's the who's the little
kid with the pirate hat that shows
Salizar young kid he's supposed to be
like 20 he's like a little guy but like
him but in like in the re engine so
she's a detail he looks like such a
realistic I do want to see that but yeah
I mean basically they're just rumors
going around that I think VG Chronicle
said they they've confirmed it confirmed
it okay yeah so I mean given the like
success of the other remakes
I honestly think they Capcom would be
stupid to not do it yeah there is still
that like I totally get people who are
like I rather them do Code Veronica
because I think that less again that
needs the remake more but I also get the
one a remake of the Resident Evil One
remake yeah I don't agree now as
somebody who loved the Resident Evil 1
remake is where my favorite games of all
time I'm like they already did it they
already remade it perfectly but I get
that like from a money-making
perspective like make them way more
money than like a Code Veronica would
yeah I saw someone tweet like what does
Capcom have the gain from this and like
a lot of money like god I mean I'm very
much team that I would love to play it I
can because because I think like even if
they don't do a great job of it the
original will still exist oh yeah right
I think that honestly I don't think they
would mess around with full mm-hmm
yeah I don't think so yeah I was kind of
curious like I wonder if people would be
more excited about this news if capcom
head and literally released that game on
every single platform like I wonder if
they'd just release it on GameCube and
maybe like playstation and then just
didn't port it to anything it was then
announced it but like the weird thing is
is that it's on it came out on 360 Xbox
one ps3 ps4 Nintendo Wii Nintendo switch
like Steam it's just like a long list of
ways you can already play this game that
still holds up incredibly well too so
that was my whole theory about why they
remade two and three in the
first place was because they the Capcom
loves to port games to new platforms
specifically Resident Evil
you know they've ported Resident Evil 4
5 6 they've ported the remake of one two
and three were the only real big ones
they couldn't do that with because they
were PlayStation 1 games so it made
sense like oh if we remake them they're
now easily portable like two different
systems so that made sense to me and
you're right and that like will wait why
do you need a remake resident afore you
already have the abilities to port it to
other systems so I guess it is more of
just like yeah more money I guess now
people do like playing saying things
that are higher fidelity to let's go
yeah yeah totally
I mean what's also interesting too is
like go ahead I was gonna say and you
have people who never played the first
one who didn't have those consoles
originally maybe who yeah yeah there's
there's all sorts of reasons I think I
mean we've great Final Fantasy 7 remake
yeah yeah that's you but but also just
like people who I think the if you like
are a younger person who plays games or
you haven't played games in a while or
you just started playing games going
back to older games can be really rough
yeah like a the language of resi 4 is
very different like you can see the way
that it's influenced modern action games
but unfortunately that means like unless
you've played it before going back is
all the more difficult
yeah yeah I would I would agree like I
think the design and structure that game
is like still really solid but the
aiming feels not as good
you can't walk like I think there are
certain things that they they could
change yeah remember on GameCube was the
a button to shoot they got rid of that
in other ports but you'd have to hold
the are to pull out your gun and then
you'd hit a to shoot and they're just so
weird I really thing like what are you
thinking
one of the best versions of that game is
the Wii version the motion is very good
yeah actually the Wii version of Okami
was really good too mm-hmm yeah I'm
curious though because you mentioned the
Final Fantasy remake and that is like
maybe like the extreme of like they took
that as an opportunity to dramatically
overhaul that where where this
I wonder if Capcom I wonder what
direction they go because I could see
them going the direction of we're gonna
keep it pretty faithful but it's gonna
look nicer maybe we'll update the
controls a little bit versus like a more
Resident Evil 2 reimagining like I I
don't know which one I would prefer yeah
yeah I'm not sure either I I'm curious
like how they'll cuz it seems like
there's like I guess a new Resident Evil
Canon kind of happening with all these
remakes and I'm curious to see what they
do with four story wise in order to make
that fit because I know a lot of people
probably wouldn't want them messing with
the story but at the same time they're
kind of already doing it in ways and
Resident Evil 2 and 3 and if they're
remaking four they'll probably use it as
opportunity to kind of tie it into this
they'll be kind of revised Resident Evil
narrative or is so self contained of all
the Resident Evil it's true it's like
the one that doesn't need to relate to
anything else and and if they want to
try to I guess but I don't know I don't
think they need to Adam just did a full
timeline of Resident Evil very good
which is amazing but also like just
source for yeah five minutes yes save
Evan is long but it's in depth again
just how batshit that franchise get oh I
love it it's weird that Resident Evil 4
is kind of on the scale of things
relatively normal
I think four has a level of
self-awareness to it yeah it kind of
knows it's dumb and spots like when you
have like the kid like Salazar dude in
the castle you're like oh okay okay
we're playing that's what this kind of
game is some of those other resin evils
though maybe take themselves a little a
little too seriously
I want them to remake five and six
I'm just kidding anyway this is why take
another crack at six you can only make
it better this first listener question
is long but we had to include it because
the subject was my piss filled a trusty
sixty controller who wants to read this
one it's a long life all right Kelly you
go for it
hey everyone loved the pod and I'm using
the current nightmare scenario we're all
living in to catch up just finished
episode 30 where someone wrote in about
buying something from a game store that
was filled with piss and I can relate to
that story some years ago I had a broken
wired xbox360 controller I needed to
replace the shell was cracked up and the
sticks were totally worn off so I went
to my local Gamestop and bought a used
replacement controller when I got the
controller home I immediately put it to
use
the controller had some issues so I
grabbed a screwdriver to open it up with
after removing the screws I started to
open the controller first the smell hit
me like stepping into the house of my
aunt who owned too many cats on a hot
summer day the stench was strong it
really paints a picture doesn't it with
the top of the 360 controller out of the
way I then moved the board of the
controller aside and to my horror found
a small pool of urine sitting in the
back portion of the controller shell how
did this happen in retrospect 360
controllers apparently sealed up nicely
as I didn't catch a whiff of anything at
all before opening the controller but
also it wasn't sealed up well enough to
keep the piss from coming in it also had
been in the controllers long enough that
the metal components and the controller
were starting to corrode I then had an
idea I tossed the guts to the piss
controller soaked everything else in a
cleaning solution for a few hours took
the guts from the other busted
controller I owned placed it into the
now pistolas shell and it was good as
new
needless to say that became the player
to controller though
game with that controller became a point
of pride among my friends was the pest
control oh yeah I suppose I could have
just returned it but it was a Game Stop
that I frequented so I felt very
self-conscious about returning a piss
fields controller I couldn't tell them
it was filled with piss because that
meant I opened the controller how did
they not know though how did the person
they said was steam stop well I guess so
what would you all have done in this
scenario do what I did throw the
controller out or try to exchange the
controller for a different one if you
think you would try to exchange it how
would you handle this exchange would you
be like yo someone peed in or on this
controller I think I need a new one also
have you ever fixed it II think before
preferably gave me related but all
stories welcome also also how did piss
find its way into my controller thanks
Kevin
from Mentor Ohio I love this so many
questions so I mean I I'm eating that
yeah that controller No so he says like
when I go to the control home it had
some issues I would have I wouldn't even
get to the piss-filled stage I would
have taken him back then and there
yeah that's probably opened a controller
like I understand anything cuz I would
be too afraid of I mean I'd I have key I
have done that yeah I am the controller
yeah I just gonna controller and I had
to clean it no it was like I think it
was like oh it was like a day or the day
I got like my ps4 like launched ps4 I
accidentally spilled orange soda on the
controller so all the buttons got sticky
so I was like I have to so I had to like
unscrew it and then like clean out like
all the buttons and stuff so that they
totally worked after that so I I guess I
guess to answer that one of the
questions I have opened up and fixed a
controller before
from my own stupidity my ps2 oh sorry
Kylie go ahead I was just gonna say to
your point on returning it when it
didn't work very well depends if my dad
was there cuz if my dad was there he
would have opened up the controller but
I am too afraid you said no but if I had
found I have this in a controller I
would have thrown it away I don't that's
money yeah you just have to say goodbye
a small pool smoke who's peeing who's
peeing like how was it like a cat pee on
the controller like was an animal that
peed on or near the controller no I
think I think it was like it was someone
like I'm taking this back the game stop
would you do that if your animal peed on
a controller would you throw it away or
would you say like maybe I can make a
couple dollars off quickly wipe the
outside and see what I'm doing this is
360 so maybe maybe the the thumb sticks
like there's a little yeah I could pull
them up that's my theory this is like
like a riddle I I'm gonna fall down this
hole solve it this is my wicked we could
do some tests on video we could like
simulate we could make it okay no a
different type of website mate no no no
with like water we need some water and
we'll like try and like figure it out we
could be some yellow Gatorade or on the
controller trying to figure out should
move on to the next question sure
actually these gonna read these two
together but they're from the discord
server Robert J and Forrest oh here we
go
do you guys have any games books or TV
shows that you wish you could wipe from
your memory so you could relive the
experience all over again that was from
Robert J and then for Estelle followed
that up with what about the opposite are
there any games you wish you knew
nothing about but I don't want to go
through for whatever reason
everything about wish you know
everything about for that one I would
say final fantasy 14
I don't have the time to play it but
dance was an answer I wish I could skip
that intro stuff oh my god that's the
thing like hearing about the intro and
knowing how much time that people put
into it I wish I had the time and I want
like I don't they're apparently doing it
all so hopefully it's better but that's
a real that's a good answer
what about something you want to
experience all over again
ooh Mass Effect trilogy yeah easily yeah
Oh Last of Us Last of Us undertale
detail so I I'm in that position I would
like eternal sunshine eternal sunshine
from my mind to relive that again books
I would say the shining for the first
time ever read The Shining Oh actually
no The Shining that covers me for books
and movies because that's pretty much my
favorite film I would love to go back in
and not like experience for the first
time but I guess well kind of like I
would love to watch some movies that I
had spoiled for me like the twist like
without having had the twist like I
would love to watch yeah exactly like
sick sense like I would love to see sick
sense blinds Oh or like Terminator 2
like I'd love to watch Terminator 2 and
like not know what I was thinking I
think yeah like movies that like I kind
of knew the big twist and I would love
to experience those fresh Darth Vader
being Luke's father can you imagine like
not that yeah uh my friend had that
experience not he didn't have it but he
he knew somebody they had a guy who was
staying at their house he was from South
Africa and he had never seen Star Wars
at all so they were like let's have him
watch these movies and he watched them
blind and he was like these are the
greatest movies ever made it was like
that's like so cool it's like this guy
in 2015 and his 30s who like had a fresh
experience of Star Wars like wow that's
so cool I wish I could have that that
sounds rad yeah I would say like I would
say movies from my childhood that I have
like The Princess Bride I pretty much
I've committed to memory now mm-hmm but
if I could watch that again fresh I
would do that in hobby I think I think
it was serious business in the discord
said guests mine which was danganronpa I
would love to replay the danganronpa
trilogy mmm fresh that would be
incredible
I also for books I would love to read
all of Gillian Flynn's books she wrote
gone girl and sharp objects and I would
love to read those fresh again I really
love murder mysteries and it's kind of
they're not really likely readable in
the same way that some other books are
yeah Twin Peaks and I also kind of had a
lot of that spoiled for me by my mum in
a conversation where I said to her that
I was going to watch Twin Peaks and she
just spoiled the ending for me
I got twin peaks' spoiled for me on
Twitter just as a coincidence literally
two episodes before I was gonna get to
the thing so uh and then for a game I
wish I could know everything about but I
don't want to actually play I would say
Final Fantasy 14 I would also say it
like the Metal Gear games like I don't
want to actually mm-hmm like I just
don't really feel like playing them but
I would love to know more about this
story um my friend actually did that I
have a friend who like didn't want to
play them so she just watched a bunch of
Let's Plays and now she like reads fan
fiction about Ocelot and stuff I love it
oh that's wonderful
yeah oh man I'm trying to think of
things I feel like you guys covered a
lot of things I would say I yeah I mean
I think the big one I last of us Witcher
I mean I don't know I feel like with The
Witcher every time I play it there's
still more things that I haven't seen
and new things and experiencing so it
kind of had it kind of has that going
for it yeah yeah yeah
I mean you could say that you wish you
could know everything about danganronpa
without playing it like actually playing
dog and Rob but they like the story but
that's a tougher one for me because I
feel like most things that I want to
know I'll actually want to put in the
effort to experience it like I do want
to actually play danganronpa at some
point you should like everyone sure yeah
yeah really like that that final thing
yeah it's it's less I want to know
everything about Final Fantasy 14 and I
just want to find a way to skip if I
could skip that opening 60 hours but
also somehow retain all the information
about it that would be great yeah for
not a game but I would love to know
everything about one piece but I don't
have time to watch yes you know what
sure yeah that's a good one do you know
a good amount about one piece
considering I've only watched so much
but yeah it's a lot mm-hmm
I really like this question I was like
yeah
hopefully we'll talk about it on the
show all right Lizzie do you want to
read the last one yeah so this is from
minute 507 two from our discord playing
- Nia what's matter at the moment and
absolutely loving it so far what is the
last thing you played / what / red god
this is hard to say played watched read
that lived up to the hype also have the
rest of y'all watched Friday Night
Lights yet whenever is Friday Night
Lights but I watched a lot of it I don't
know if it ever at least in my circle of
friends that didn't become as big as you
know we were obsessed
the OSI with Gossip Girl that kind of
thing and Gilmore Girls with Friday
night
Night Lights never really hit for us
neither did One Tree Hill actually hi
what does he say I was forced to watch
it but it was not my choice neither so
that's that on Friday night like see
this question is hard for me because I
review a lot of the games that I want to
play so there is no hype I'm the person
who has to say what it whether it's a
hype generator so it's like if I had
heard that dest ranting was good and
then I played that stranding I'd be like
wow this really lives up to the hype
because I loved that game so much but I
so I just like I don't know how to
answer this question means titanfall the
hype is real man what is hype may never
die there's no hype around titanfall
pubs no that was a pub GOG because while
and then finally I was like okay a pub
Gian and I played pub G every night for
like months hmm sorry the reason I
brought up titanfall the hype is real is
because I remember that was a box quote
from my job on titanfall that was the
hype is real and I I remember thinking
the same thing like like I was excited
for it because it was like a new IP but
like was there a lot of hype going into
it so that's why I mentioned that it's
not really what I was thinking okay dick
to Kathy's point like yeah I feel like
it's kind of different because we've
typically we play these games we hear
about these games earlier then most
people do and work kind of like trying
not to get caught up in hype for the
most part so like the one that really
came to mind for me was well before t 13
when i played bioshock infinite because
that was a game that i've been waiting a
long time for and it went through all
this all these development issues and it
took a long time and i still had very
high expectations for it because it was
Bioshock and i've been waiting so long
and for me that lived up to them i
haven't revisited that game in a long
time
but yeah that is a game that I remember
like just enjoying every second of that
game and just being so excited to
finally play it and like I thought the
ending paid off and I thought all of it
paid off I think the original I think
Brent redemption for me because that was
the one where I that was the game that I
bought my 364 I was obsessed with the
101 trailers with the in Red Dead
Redemption you played like I was
obsessed with us and it was my kind of
treat to myself finishing my year of uni
and I was like okay I mean I did it I'm
to God by 3:16 I'm gonna buy right of
redemption and I remembered like playing
through it over the course of about 3 or
4 weeks and I was obsessed with it and I
loved it and I adored the ending and I
would say that definitely look at that
for the hype I can't speak
I've been troubleshooting tech issues
all day I've gone outside in weeks it's
okay I can't speak I can't read it it's
got a hardware store earlier to get a
battery for my mic and I stood there and
I knew exactly what kind of battery I
needed it was a 9-volt battery but they
had two different kinds of 9-volt
batteries and the guy lit she carrots me
news like you all right and I was just
stood there with two of them in my
handling I think so it's fine we've got
their Red Dead Mike doesn't like
whatever red that's actually good answer
for me too because I didn't play Red
Dead until way later I remember the hype
around Red Dead I said I remember being
in my precalculus class and there was a
guy in my class whose last name was
Marston and so ever like all the guys
were like he'd just come out and they
were all about it and I remember being
like oh we should really play this game
and then I did it for like 10 years and
then I loved it and it's one of my
favorite games I've ever played
so yeah you go yeah I would say mine was
probably Mass Effect 2 I remember being
like so excited for that game it's like
it lived
- my personal hype but I don't think I
like was paying that much attention to
like outside hype it was just sort of
like my personal expectations the one
example I can think of where a plasticy
where everyone like on social media kept
hyping it up was into spider-man into
the spider-verse
Oh like everyone kept being like it's
the greatest animated movie ever and I
was like alright well it looks pretty
cool but we'll see and I walked out I'm
like okay yeah yeah everyone was right I
was really good and she parasite - I was
gonna say parasite yeah yeah people cuz
I remember just seeing all the tweets it
was a can or Sundance and I just
remember seeing tweets going Paris I got
all these awards got standing ovations
don't read up anything about it I was
like okay you know I was the same with
hereditary like and typically when I
hear that I don't watch all the trailers
and stuff I just go in fresh and I'm
yeah parasite and hereditary so we did
live out I actually haven't seen
parasite yet still that would be my one
I have to see and then I can come back
and say yep yeah it lives up tonight
yeah I guess I'm gonna test out with
Chrono Trigger cuz I downloaded Chrono
Trigger and I'm gonna play that that's a
good one
for the very first time which sold me on
it was that I looked it up and it's okay
you can finish it in like 30 hours
knowing I think yeah it's not it's not a
terribly long game anyway I think that's
a good spot to end it do you guys have
anything to add alright that's been
episode 37 of GameSpot after dark thank
you so much for tuning in if you can't
even see me cuz I can't well you'll just
see me as no signal if you enjoyed this
please leave ratings on itunes.com or if
you want to get into the discussion I
tune about all I wanted to say was you
should join the discord and if you have
any questions you can email us at after
Podcast at Gamescom and you back that's
all I got for this is Lucy cut out for
anyone else good I'm the only one who
hasn't had tech issues everyone else
it's not only something happened I'm
sure my audio will be messed up somehow
Jake go get it and it'll be a mess we're
gonna say where you can find us on
Twitter uh yeah if you want go for it
well you can find me on twitter at a
Cheeto jacob i nky DOJ I cake cake oh
and once again I am asking for your
support
watch our competitive pokemon videos you
know you have plenty of time maybe
you're interested in getting into a
really difficult niche thing check them
out
that's all I got Lucy oh I'll go I
didn't know who's going I'm at least see
James Games uh what are we doing this
week oh the resident evil timeline is
the thing that my team's been working on
it's real good
that should be going up and then we also
have another episode of true fiction
going up all about Fargo yeah true crime
in Fargo went to faves oh and good news
gaming is frightened yeah you can find
me at John Luke psyche I go watch the
Final Fantasy spoiler caster go listen
to it both the video and the audio
version are up at this point so yeah go
check that out if you've played the game
and want to hear us talk about Final
Fantasy hopefully I didn't sound too
stupid because I don't really play Final
Fantasy games so hopefully hopefully I
didn't make a fool of myself but
think it turned out pretty well so you
should go listen to that and you can
find me at Jacob deck and I should have
a follow-up video up this weekend
hopefully about fall 76 if you're
curious about that thinking about maybe
dipping into it or buying it you can
check out my video and check out the
review which I don't know if that'll be
up by that because I'm sure our reviewer
is going to do a much thorough job than
I will for my little video also if
you're listening to this on Friday the
17th make sure you weigh should shake a
happy belated birthday tomorrow he edits
this so he's gonna cut it out oh there's
a games done quick this weekend then I'm
super pumped about really yeah that's a
Friday so I feel this inches oh my god
which games done quick oh that's my
weekend yeah one of the final ones is
kingdom hearts 2 final mix so I am oh my
god the Kingdom Hearts ones are always
there like five hours long or like some
nonsense oh my god anyway
[Music]